Як ми звикли в Україні сприймати Полтаву?
Ми звикли, що Полтава — це галушки,
Котляревський, можливо.
Якщо хтось там любить читати.
Ми звикли, що це Полтавська битва.
Але, по суті, Полтава — це прикордонне місто.
А на прикордонні, на фронтирі,
завжди відбуваються найцікавіші історії.
Мені здається, Полтава є дуже цікавою
і нерозкритою саме з погляду кордонів.
Мистецьких кордонів, ментальних кордонів,
мовних кордонів, суспільних кордонів.
Мене звуть Олександр, але на війні
я більше звик до імені Олекса.
І я народився під Полтавою.
Загалом, майже все життя, за винятком
різних ротацій і мандрівок, я жив тут.
А за діяльністю я зараз, по суті,
співвласник ІТ-компанії, ветеранський бізнес.
Мене завжди дуже цікавила тема архетипів.
Мені здається, що є таке
поняття як квазі-архетипи —
певні тимчасові утворення
з колективного підсвідомого.
Я хотів писати з цього наукову роботу.
Коли закінчував магістратуру, я тоді…
Так сталося, що я заснував студентський рух.
А цей студентський рух запустив у Полтаві «Майдан».
[сміється]
І так сталося, що якраз коли я
закінчував магістратуру, почалася війна.
Закінчився «Майдан».
І я віддав свою магістерську друзям.
Кажу: «Ви її віднесете».
І поїхав на Схід добровольцем.
Потім, після війни,
мене постійно «накривало».
Тобто я випадав у якусь прострацію.
Згадував похорони друзів,
згадував певні критичні моменти.
І якось я просто прокинувся...
І перша думка в мене була,
що треба купити фарби.
І щось намалювати.
Приїхав додому, в мене якраз була обідня перерва.
Я просто сів і виключився на 4 години.
Це було таке абсолютне занурення.
Я ніколи не думаю над тим, що малюю.
Для мене взагалі не важливе місце, де я малюю.
Коли залишаюсь наодинці з пензлем
або з мастихіном, я вимикаю всю свідомість.
В мене є лише рука.
Немає Олекси, немає Полтави.
Є просто рука, і рука щось розповідає.
Для мене малювання —
це просто дуже крутий інструмент,
який навчив мене бути тут і зараз.
Перший раз, коли ти приїжджаєш,
тебе все дратує дуже сильно.
Тому що ти розумієш,
що в тебе днями загинув твій друг.
А люди, які тут, вони навіть не знають цього друга.
Вони не знають, чому він загинув.
Але потім ми йшли в піцерію
в Дніпрі, після повернення.
І хтось з побратимів — ну це у всіх,
загалом, ветеранів ця тема.
Хтось з ветеранів озвучив ці думки вголос.
А інший ветеран, який…
він в Афгані ще воював, здається.
Ну такий класний дуже чувак був.
Він каже, послухай:
«Ну але ж по суті, по великому рахунку,
ми ж з тобою сьогодні там зранечку
були в окопі саме для того,
щоб ці люди, які ходять по цих вулицях,
не знали, що таке війна,
і насолоджувались життям, і були щасливими».
І потім, коли я вже повернувся, звільнився.
Незважаючи на це розуміння,
було дуже важко психологічно.
Тобто це постійно якісь сни,
постійно якісь «флешбеки».
І до того ж коло спілкування
просто нульове.
Ну тобто з побратимами можеш поговорити.
А з іншого боку, я зловживав алкоголем
кілька місяців після повернення.
Але в якийсь момент просто
зрозумів, що мені це нудно.
І збагнув, що треба щось шукати,
щоб було не нудно.
Єдиний варіант вийти з внутрішнього пекла,
з внутрішнього такого самокатування — це прийняття.
І прийняття якраз приходить завдяки
тому, що ти відчуваєш себе тут і зараз.
І от малювання — це один з цих інструментів.
Але це може бути гончарство,
це може бути різьба по дереву.
Це може бути будь-що,
де ви відчуєте цей момент.
Фішка, щоб саме зачепитись за щось,
в чому ти зможеш стабілізувати час.
Малювання — це як перевести годинник.
Перевести годинник на цю хвилину.
В ХХ-ХХІ століттях у фільмах,
в книгах, в музиці, в живописі,
дуже багато трендів, які пов’язані зі смертю
або з колосмертними переживаннями.
Але в нас немає культу життя.
Оці люди там, ветерани, повернулися.
Скажіть їм «дякую» просто,
потисніть їм руку.
Скажіть їм: «Ви — молодці».
Тому що, коли герой живий,
він не потрібен в Україні.
А коли герой помер...
[помпезно розмахує руками]
Культ смерті — це надзвичайно погана річ.
А нам потрібно впроваджувати культ життя.
Алло, Дім, я в парку, але не можу тебе знайти.
А де?
А біля чого?
Я зараз біля фонтану у Сонячному [парку].
О! Я бачу Рому з пуфиками.
А ще хтось підійшов? О, ось він.
Привіт!
— Вибач, я трішки в фарбі.
— Нічого страшного.
Нам сюди.
Коли я знову повернувся до,
так би мовити, життя,
я продовжив, проходити різні курси.
Працював у багатьох проєктах
з адаптації співтренером.
І мені здається, що в процесі
адаптації запускати такі курси,
на яких інші ветерани можуть бути в одній спільноті
з іншими ветеранами — це найкрутіше.
Тобто психологічна адаптація працює.
Уявіть, у нас в Полтаві,
є безпечне місце, де можна прийти
і можна в максимально безпечній атмосфері,
знаючи, що ніхто не буде виносити
це кудись назовні, те, що ти будеш говорити.
І свої думки.
Ти можеш просто прийти посидіти
з однодумцями, з ветеранами.
Можеш просто прийти, зарядитись
якимось новими думками, ідеями.
Якщо людина висловлює думки,
з якими ви не погоджуєтеся,
необов'язково давати поради, необов'язково
критикувати, необов'язково там...
— Нав'язувати.
— Нав'язувати, так, свою позицію.
Тобто це безпечна платформа.
І він приходить на цю точку безпеки і бачить,
що є люди в цьому місті, які його розуміють.
[ведуть нечутну розмову]
Найбільша проблема в питанні адаптації,
щоб ветерани могли знаходити роботу,
в якій вони можуть відчувати
плюс-мінус таку ж важливість,
яку  відчували, коли захищали лінію фронту.
Я особисто не знаю, як це зробити в селах.
Запитую постійно ветеранів
з різних регіонів: «Що ви робите із селами?».
Мені в Миколаєві розказали,
що вони приїжджають в село, тобто...
Це така чудова історія.
Був ветеран, він пиячив.
Вони його запитали: «Чого ти хочеш в житті?».
А він каже: «Хотів би свинарник.
Але немає грошей».
Через тиждень вони йому привезли свиней.
Він перестав пиячити.
Тоді вони приїжджають до нього через місяць,
а в нього вже свиноматка вагітна.
І що роблять ці ветерани?
Село.
Вони приходять до нього, на його локацію.
І кажуть: «Ви знаєте взагалі
з ким ви живете в селі?
Та це ж герой Дебальцева,
який в танку відбив атаку».
І всі в селі: «Ого!».
І це дуже хороша річ.
Тобто його рівень актуалізації
одразу отутечки [піднімає руки вгору].
Коли я пішов вчитись в ІТ, через рік,
мабуть, чи через півтора року,
я дізнався, що мій побратим
з Дніпра також пішов в ІТ.
Я кажу: «Чувак, є “Ветерано піца”,
зробімо “Ветерано ІТ”».
Через рік кажу: «Чувак, це працює.
Нумо запустимо курси для ветеранів».
І цього року в мене вже
буде третій набір на курси.
За цей час в мене було 250 ветеранів,
які вчились на курсах безкоштовно.
Сьогодні ми поспілкуємося на дві теми.
Ми сьогодні розглянемо усі ваші роботи
по проєктах, які ви анонсували.
Це з одного боку.
А з іншого боку — ми сьогодні розглянемо нову тему.
Я думаю, що ви вже починали
пробувати знайомитися з препроцесорами.
Але перед тим як починати їх застосовувати, я помічав,
що багато хто з новачків не розуміє для чого це.
Це можна порівняти з тим, коли ти бачиш
якісь нові аксесуари для своєї зброї.
І спочатку, можливо,
ти не розумієш для чого вони.
Але потім, в якийсь момент,
ти вже не можеш без них жити.
Тому, в принципі, з препроцесорами
така сама ситуація.
Це був вебінар стандартний,
сьогодні ми говорили про препроцесори.
Це такі штуки, які полегшують
написання стилів
І розбирали частково роботу ветеранів.
Тобто там ідея полягає в тому, що ми даємо їм такі
практичні завдання, які мають стосунок до світу
Тобто це або якісь замовлення безкоштовні,
які вони перші можуть брати для портфоліо.
Або це може бути...
В мене є така ідея: спрямовувати ветеранів
на розбудову українського контенту.
Тобто я хотів би...
Може наступного року чи через два роки,
запускати курси з розрахунком створення
цілих порталів українського контенту.
Умовно кажучи, це може бути якийсь надзвичайно
цікавий портал про Голодомор.
Або надзвичайно цікавий портал про періоди,
коли забороняли українську мову.
Але це графічно можна так чудово зробити,
що тобі захочеться поділитися цим з кимось.
Ідея полягає в тому, що ми поєднуємо навчання,
бо такі речі вони доволі складні.
Вони дуже цінні.
А з іншого боку — це український контент.
Одного разу я сів і задумався, як мені
знайти актуалізацією своєї роботи,
яка в мене була на війні.
І потім зрозумів, що треба в роботі
із замовником піти шляхом архетипів.
І зараз, коли до нас приходить замовник,
ми позиціонуємо його як Одіссея,
Улісса або якогось героя.
Тобто ми — не герої,
а замовник — наш герой.
Перша річ — ми поділяємо його цінності.
У нас дуже багато вимог до замовника [сміється].
І буває так, що ми відмовляємо проєктам.
Якщо ми поділяємо цінності проєкту замовника,
то у нас є така «фішка»,
що ми намагаємося розкрити його
додатковий соціальний потенціал.
Це може бути як і просто контент.
Тобто ми там декільком проєктам пропонували:
«А давайте ми зробимо на вашій базі,
що ви будете найбільшим україномовним порталом на цю тему»
Бо вони спочатку російською хотіли,
а ми їм: «А російською багато порталів.
А зробімо вас найбільшим
україномовним порталом на цю тему»
По суті, це наші позиціонування,
що IT BRO — це вояки для ваших веб-проєктів.
Тобто ми перенесли наші цінності
з війни на цінності в бізнесі.
І якщо в нас там є вибір між
кількома проєктами, то ми, звісно,
будемо обирати, навіть
якщо там буде менший прибуток,
якийсь проєкт, що має
певну соціальну орієнтацію,
яка створює певні нові змісти для локації.
Але найголовніше знову ж те, що частина з ветеранів,
яким «зайшло» ІТ, знайшла роботу.
В мене є такий документ, де зберігаю листи
від людей, яким я зробив щось хороше.
І я передивляюсь ці листи, коли в мене там...
Не знаю... Я заморився дуже.
І в мене якраз нещодавно був такий лист:
«Чувак, пів року тому я взагалі не знав, чим займатися.
Мене вчора запросили в англійську
компанію працювати дистанційно.
Завдяки вашим курсам».
Чуваки, я не знаю як вам віддячити!».
А я кажу: «Ти вже віддячив.
Просто розказав і цього вже достатньо».
Якщо ми візьмемо всіх українців
і зліпимо з них одну людину,
і подивимося на її життя
за останні сто років, то побачимо,
що це надзвичайно травмована особистість.
І, відповідно, ця людина потребує адаптації.
Потребує роботи з психологами.
Тому, мені здається, що українцям
потрібні не політики чи економісти...
Зрозуміло, що нам потрібні класні економісти.
Але нам потрібні не транші.
Нам потрібні класні психологи,
які будуть працювати в містах,
селах, селищах міського типу з людьми.
І будуть пояснювати їм, що означає
брати відповідальність за своє життя,
як перестати звинувачувати всіх у всьому.
І так далі.
Тому що без цього нічого не запуститься. Нічого.
Якщо ми навчимося бути тут і зараз.
Якщо ми будемо вчитися гідності.
В розумінні вчитися поважати себе.
Якщо ми будемо вчитися поважати інших.
Якщо ми будемо це транслювати.
Якщо ми будемо говорити про це як про запити.
Я думаю, що це також працюватиме,
без глибокої психології.
І те, яке середовище ти навколо себе вибудовуєш...
У динаміці є такий принцип, як динаміка.
Тобто ми пояснюємо ветеранам:
«Ти можеш випити таблетку і тобі стане добре.
Але завтра буде вдвічі гірше.
Ти можеш зробити десять оцих вправ
із своїм тілом, із своєю психікою.
І завтра тобі на 0,01 % стане краще.
Післязавтра тобі стане на 0,02 % краще».
Оцей принцип динаміки працює в усьому.
В плані буття і гідності, якщо щодня,
потрохи, у своєму оточенні щось змінювати,
буде зміна в країні.